[Applause]
i noticed you were hitting another level
when i saw connor mention you because
connor i think is on like marketing mode
24 7
right so whoever has the most gravity
he's trying to attach himself to that
gravity and he's trying to attach
himself to that story right
so while it's really cool
and or maybe annoying that he's doing it
it is
it is important to note that this is
where he notices the gravity going
right he's going i might have to come up
to 170 you're not coming up to 170.
i don't even know how you make 170 dude
when you were on top of the cage
bro it was different when you were on
top of it
you had titty muscles on your titty
muscles bro
it was it was one of the most
unbelievable things i've ever seen
so there's no way conor could come up
but the fact that he's he's coming after
the gravity you created
you know you're entering a different
stratosphere right now
no absolutely and and that's the thing
with uh my manager as well
he recognizes that he's very smart you
know shout out to my manager
um you know connor is
is you know conor is connor
yeah we have to give him props for what
he's done and and the space that he's
put himself in but at this point he gets
a little bit
corny and he gets a little bit you know
we're in this age of all these clout
chasers and people always continuing to
steal
cloud and and conor is getting to the
point where it's
if i can't create it myself anymore
mm-hmm then i'll just
i'm just going to chirp and get to
whoever
is got it you know when when
is he israel out of sight on your fights
our boy oh my boy
when izzy fights boom conor's tweeting
about something
yeah you know and it's like he's like
why why are you trying to steal some of
that shine why are you
that's not what's going on right you
take a seat young man you know it's not
your turn right now
but he can't stand it or where someone
else goes he can't stand it he has to
speak up
and and in that space that's where he's
at right now
you know and connor's saying i might
have to come up he's let's
he's mentioned before he said ah that
170 belt is looking
looking quite good i gave him an
opportunity
i said hey you want to fight for the
belt here you can fight for the belt
during uh um i believe right before uh
the covert app
right i said yo you can fight for the
belt here
he said nothing went silent radio
science didn't hear
anything yeah two days later anderson
silva does an interview about
you know potentially fighting connor
connor goes i accept
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now you're so
my man
it just it looks bad for you right now
because at the end of the day
if you want to fight me pick up that
phone call call dana and say dana
i want to fight that guy and and you
know
let's be honest it's kind of hard to shy
away from that
it's hard for me to shy away from a
fight period i was shy away from fights
yeah but um
if it's conor mcgregor let's be honest
yeah it's hard to shy away from that one
you know it's very hard to shy away from
that one so if conor really wanted to
come up
he would do it he won't get on twitter
and and turn into twitter fingers and
basically just start tweeting and
chasing cloud here
you know i'm not into that business i'm
into the hurt business and uh and i'm
starting to do that very well
yeah i think you are go out let me ask
you this conor wants to fight you
what do you want because now they're
still i'm starting to hear casual guy
oh this is one of the greatest ever
maybe so what do you want to do
to get to the point where it's like oh
that's the [ __ ] goat
the crazy thing for me is i i just i
can't i try not to
even think about that i can't think
about that i don't i don't want to worry
about that
i've seen a few guys uh start thinking
about that
a guy that actually ruled in my division
for a little while was
starting to make those statements and
say those yes i'm this i'm that i'm this
i'm that
instead of worrying about the next one
in front of you next one
my full focus is on the next guy in
front of me
now i go out there and i take out that
next guy guess what there's gonna be
another next guy
boom i take out that guy there's gonna
be another next guy
you continue to do that and you do it
long enough people are gonna be like
holy sh
look at this yeah look what this guy's
done and so
that's just where i try to focus my mind
and my attention
and when i'm when i'm done with it and i
walk away i'm gonna look back and i can
say
wow damn i did that [ __ ]
yeah yeah
you